yes yes a huge
audience
massive happy whatever day it is
everyone all right control yourselves
thousands of
people so imagine you're on a subway and
some wild man strikes your wife in the
face before you can react a bunch of
activists jumps between you and the
attacker to keep you from protecting her
in fact they're screaming that it's your
fault how would you feel pretty much
like Israel here in America as War rages
our nation's caring progressives aren't
being asked to do anything much all they
do is the easy stuff they protest from
afar over the weekend 7,000 progressives
took to the streets in the People's
Republic of Brooklyn shutting down the
bridge true during those hours there
wasn't a barista or women's studies
Professor left anywhere in
town and really it's a wonder we still
have an obesity problem in this country
with all the marching they
do the Mars carried banners like honor
the martyrs and from The River To The
Sea a phrase which Advocates the
complete eradication of Israel it's
either that or the condition of Joe
Biden's depends after three IC
te I know I felt bad about that
protected by the same cops they were
likely throwing things at during George
Floyd's Summer of Love two years ago
these Brave Weekend Warriors banged
drums and instagrammed every moment of
Saturday afternoon's fight against the
man yes the man it's the only time where
that pronoun is
acceptable but walking into in the
street screaming ceasefire now is no
great imposition especially when you're
not the one getting fired on like those
young people in the desert it's like
lecturing someone who's been doused in
kerosene about the dangers of secondhand
smoke even better after this display of
compassion you'll be back to your
Playstation in no time of course
protesting here solves nothing quite the
opposite for the protest here enables
other people over there to do even more
harm than they've already done it's why
your simplistic world view of standing
with the oppressed is completely invalid
you don't really stand with the
oppressed you're Marching for extra
credit and you aren't sacrificing a
thing instead you're adding to the
Mayhem through approval because while
you protest others who are actually In
Harm's Way will have to sacrifice
there's compulsory military in Israel
for a reason because the bullets and
bombs they face aren't on a video screen
they're real so you can protest against
them but you're protesting against their
survival at no cost to you and oddly you
don't protest other things like for
example the Ukraine war funny how no one
shuts down the Brooklyn Bridge over that
in Russia LS even stormed an Israeli
flight but not a Ukrainian one they
demanded to know who were the Jews and
it wasn't to invite them to next year's
Ros Shana seder I don't even know if I
said that
right Catholic School hundreds of
thousands are already dead in Russia's
expansionist war on Ukraine and America
is paying for it in billions and
billions of tax money so where's the
campus outrage over that hell
misgendering a 50-year-old man dressed
in a tutu will get these idiots more
pissed off so what's the difference
could it be a pigment problem if only
white people die who gives a and so the
crazy man on the Subway gets a free shot
at your wife cuz she's not an approved
marginalized group with the proper skin
color and that's the mechanism which
chooses for the gullible and lazy
protester which side they should be on
if you default automatically to
oppressed versus oppressor you end up
protesting a potential War following an
unspeakable atrocity as opposed to a
wasteful war that you've been paying for
well that we've been paying for not
those dead beat Dead beats who are
protesting so if you were out there in
the per perfect Autumn weather screaming
phrases like by any means necessary
maybe you should get off the bridge take
off the checkered headscarf and ask
yourself this is clinging to the white
oppressor mindset really leading to good
decisions when it leads you to side with
a pre-modern terrorist group that
beheads babies a group that wouldn't
tolerate your beloved multiculturalism
for a nanc that treats women like
property and gaze like monsters I don't
see too many Rainbow Flags in Palestine
do you
so do you really want Hamas as an ally
over the mid east's only genuinely
developed pluralistic society in other
words do you really hate western
civilization and hate yourself that much
all these protests this weekend would
have been braver on October 6th warning
Hamas against violence but that's like
warning The View against
Donuts they also would have been braver
on October 8th condemning Hamas after
the atrocities but Weeks Later safe ly
protected by a tolerant Society they
hate all this was just detached
performative passion brought bought and
paid for that only preserves a terror
sect and does nothing for the cause of
Peace they're screaming so violently
about it but they don't mean it the
American system is and was an experiment
in the concept of Live and Let Live it's
actual diversity not the one you always
hear about that's about as fake as Dylan
mulan's
tits but now we see the tools to sustain
the experiment are being smashed why is
Israel hated because compared to the
rest of the Middle East it looks a lot
like us it look looks like a western
civilization that a few coddled College
professors have convinced half the
electorate needs to be destroyed because
it's institutionally racist turns out
the river to the Sea isn't just the
Jordan River to the Mediterranean it's
the Mississippi to the Atlantic and
Pacific as well but Israel is something
we're also not it's cohesive so as they
fight fight side by side we end up
turning on ourselves thanks to the
oppressed mindset we aren't capable of
understanding what Israel is fighting
for their very existence because we're
here too busy fighting
us let's welcome T night's
guests like Halloween candy you should
always check him for pins and razor
blades Fox News contributor Charlie
hurs she's not a ghost but you can still
call her boo host of the fox True Crime
podcast Emily
capano he didn't even know it was
Halloween that's just how he dresses
host of fox Across America Jimmy
Bor and tonight she'll scare children by
talking about the deficit New York Times
bestselling author and Fox News
contributor
cat Charlie always good to see you great
to see you really happy Halloween happy
Halloween to you what are you going as
uh just myself ah well someone has to I
guess so the scary part about this is
that you always hope that the old
extremism would die off but we realize
it just gets passed along there's a
whole new generation out there that
hates the West oh yeah oh yeah and I
think your point is exactly right about
Israel the reason they hate it so much
is because it is the only Western Nation
over there and you know and and when you
turn on the TV and you see these
protests happening in our country and
you're like this is not America you know
we we are blessed in that we are the the
the one country that is built on a Creed
on an idea we're not you know we were
not we've not been Shackled by race and
religion and all this was the place
where everybody can come and check your
racism or check your bigotry at the door
and come here and abide by these ideas
and we all get along and we all make
money the only know and and and and you
know can't be surprised by when our
polit you have an entire political party
in in uh our country that is solely
devoted to dividing people by race and
democrats for the past 15 years their
their uh identity politics is all about
racializing everybody and the result of
it is what you see here you have these
two sides uh you know fighting over uh
basically having racial fights and we've
seen it going back through all of the
all of the protests mhm for the past
three years yeah if you eliminate the
variable of actually cohabitating
together this is what you're going to
get they're arguing for segregation or
War you know I am Pro protest Emily I'm
lying but I am I am do do you find do
you find that these protests are any way
helpful or they rather Instead
self-indulgent self-indulgent at a
minimum I I think they are a joke we've
talked about this before that these
protesters um are doing the work of
these terrorist organizations for them
they represent the West that Hamas and
others have sworn to eradicate and
Destroy they think that they would be
celebrated over there that queers and
solidarity and those other ridiculous
signs not realizing that they too would
be slaughtered and butchered and those
Neo fites taking off time from Starbucks
to go walk there and and ruin our city
uh to me represent again the success of
what has been a campaign to socially
agitate this entire country and to take
over college campuses and you can call
it Socialism or communism or just
straight up an Insidious spread of
hatred and when you talk about the you
know anti-semitic organizations and
groups they have been it has been
codified in global groups that this
Administration never questions and
that's one thing that I loved about
Trump he said why United Nations tell me
about NATO what are we contributing you
know those of you who just pay your
bills and what are you getting from
those bills exactly so the United
Nations has condemned Israel more times
than any other country combined they
have failed to condemn last year even
once China Venezuela cutter all of those
Scot free Canada deserves it the most
yes and yet they also moved for the
international criminal court to
investigate Israel criminally
internationally criminal court for what
they've said was the and that's the body
that we're supposed to be using to to
acknowledge or move for a ceasefire why
that is the body that has codified and
embodies anti-Semitism and it's why in
part it's spread everywhere and become
acceptable I wish we had a
commander-in-chief or a secretary of
state or a director of the CIA that
would stand up and say not on our watch
but it remains to be seen whether that
will happen in
2024 well said spicy you know uh Jimmy
can you compare the hatred from these
pramas protesters to the audiences after
attending one of your
shows
ah they love me are you kidding me look
at me okay I'm not I'm not like a chip
Andale I'm more like a chips in Dale
like a little chubby but there's two
there two don't laugh at that sh but
there is there's two dueling factions
here there's a big chunk of this that is
legitimate anti-Semitism and those
people need to be careful because if you
keep saying anti-semitic things
Democrats will send you to Congress okay
that's a thing I going to do that but
the other faction is and this is
identity politics it can it caters to
intellectually lazy people meaning
stupid people and I say that because
like 34 of the people on the Brooklyn
Bridge this weekend chanting kill the
Jews live in an apartment with a hate
has no home here sticker on the door or
a coexist sticker you know what I'm
saying having these idiot guys on the
bridge then Gaza Strip is a gentleman's
club they have no idea and they're
marching like this is what we're doing
now but protest has become and that's
all you should be chanting this is what
we're doing now cuz this is defund the
police it's no
River to the Sea it's the same idiots
and they're now contradicting themselves
that's what's so stupid that
contradiction cat it's true many of
these protests protesters probably
protested against like right-wing
violence and now they're calling for an
elimination of Israel they're not saying
out well some of them are from the
rivers whatever what say you from the
rivers whatever uh I well it's weird but
I think that Jimmy had a lot of good
points Jimmy well be honestly I mean
look think that it's obviously
completely human to really feel for
innocent civilians anywhere who are
suffering um but then of course there's
some of these people who are just
straight up like the terrorism is okay
which obviously that's gross and that's
and all that but you know I think that
you're right I think that a lot of these
people they don't really think it
through that much they're like okay I've
heard this is the thing that I'm
supposed to be saying I'm supposed to
have this take or I'm supposed to have
that take I don't think anybody really
thinks that much about it because it's
just too complicated and difficult
they'd rather just go with all their
friends are doing thank you but to your
other point about marches the one reason
I support this is a lot of those women
did need the exercise okay maybe instead
of occupying the bridge you occupy a
treadmill and they were so close to the
water they could have taken a bath yeah
but that's great some of you need to lay
off the Hamas and go with some Hamas you
know what I'm saying well said hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else